ja also energie wird knapp die preise
steigen darüber spreche ich mit dem
präsidenten des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung professor marcel
fritsche schönen guten morgen
guten morgen frau nicht der
bundeswirtschaftsminister der warnt vor
einem albtraum szenario der bayerische
ministerpräsident söder vor einem
schlaganfall der wirtschaft für wie
bedrohlich halten sie die situation
die situation ist bedrohlich allerdings
sollte man jetzt auch nicht den teufel
an die wand malen die politik ist in der
pflicht hier eine versorgungssicherheit
sicherzustellen aber das was eben nicht
eben angeklungen ist wir haben schon für
viele menschen heute eine notsituation
nicht weil es eine knappheit gibt
sondern weil die preise explodiert sind
und gerade menschen mit geringen
einkommen müsste ja jetzt schon 150 200
euro mehr im monat für lebensmittel für
energie gerade für gas auch zahlen und
viele menschen befinden sich jetzt schon
in der notsituation können sich viele
dinge nicht leisten müssten jetzt
verzicht üben und das ist also wir
brauchen gar nicht erst warten auf das
problem wir haben schon jetzt eine krise
ebene anderen form in form von höheren
preisen also das haben sie jetzt eben
angesprochen die menschen haben ein
problem mit den preisen befürchten sie
auch massive proteste dann wie die
weltbesten proteste die bewegung in
frankreich
wir können uns das in deutschland nicht
vorstellen aber wir haben eine
zunehmende soziale polarisierung und
es ist ja nicht erst jetzt durch den
krieg und durch die höhere inflation wir
haben das seit zehn jahren die
explodierenden mieten in den städten
viele menschen zahlen mittlerweile 35 40
45 fast die hälfte ihres monatlichen
einkommens zum wohnen wir haben jetzt in
der planie gesehen dass die schere
weiter auf geht s am arbeitsmarkt aber
vor allem auch bei gesundheit und
bildung und die frage ist nicht ob die
menschen dort sich wehren werden sondern
mehr die frage wie es aussehen wird ob
seiner wahl ohne sein wird ob man die
etablierten politischen parteien
abstrafen wird ob es zu protesten ob es
zu unruhen kommt aber in der einen oder
anderen form wird sich das äußern und
die politik ist gut beraten jetzt diese
notsituation auch zu erkennen und zu
handeln und
das noch nicht passiert genau das ist
die frage also haben sie das gefühl die
regierung tut eigentlich noch nicht
genug weil wir hören ja immer wieder
dass das problem erkannt sei also gerade
in bezug auf inflation und
einkommensschwache haushalte die
politik macht etwas aber eben wenig es
gab es hier zwei entlastungs paket mit
30 milliarden euro die aber nicht
wirklich die menschen am unteren ende
gezielt entlastet haben sondern das war
er per gießkannenprinzip rentnerinnen
und rentner sind dort viel zu wenig
berücksichtigt worden vor allem die
sozialleistungen menschen die hartz 4
die in der grundrente erzielen die
können die haben kein schutzmechanismus
und also ist die antwort auf ihre fragen
an die politik tut noch nicht genug um
die menschen die wirklich hilfe
benötigen die keine schutzmechanismen
haben zu entlasten und das gilt es jetzt
dringend zu tun denn die menschen kam
keine zeit da können sie nicht sagen
wartet mal ein halbes jahr dann haben
wir schon eine lösung die menschen die
brauchen jetzt dringend geld in die
tasche denn die situation wird nicht
besser sondern eher in den kommenden
monaten noch einmal deutlich schlechter
die grüne umweltministerin lembke die
plädiert ja für ein gas preismoratorium
also für eine preisobergrenze was halten
sie davon ließe sich dadurch denn
tatsächlich etwas tun
ein gaspreis deckel wäre sehr klug den
russen zu sagen mir wir zahlen euch
summe ickx und nicht mehr dazu müssten
aber alle europäern auch global
mitmachen das ist also ein
koordinationsprobleme und auch dann weiß
man nicht wie wird es funktionieren denn
wenn wir sehen bei nord süd 2001 das
eben die gasmengen gedrosselt werden
vielleicht sogar komplett abgestellt
werden und ja da wird es dann weniger
ein problem nur des preises sondern eben
auch der liefermengen da wird also auch
ein preis deckel so sinnvoller ist nicht
helfen klar ist die politik braucht
lösungen man könnte das zum beispiel bei
einer gaspreis deckelung bei den
verbraucherinnen verbrauchern machen
dass man sagt für eine gewisse
grundmenge die dringend notwendig ist um
zu heizen und zu kochen im winter
beispielsweise
setzt der staat ein deckel und
kompensiert die anbieter dementsprechend
das wäre eine möglichkeit aber die
menschen brauchen jetzt schnell hilfe
nochmals die preise sind schon extrem
hoch die menschen belastet deshalb muss
die politik hier nachlegen sagt der
präsident des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung marcel fritsche
vielen dank für das interview